- We've reached that part of the show
where I offer something
magical from the internet.
This is what I'm liking.
(playful guitar music)
Earlier I spoke with D Smoke,
who was a teacher turned rapper.
So to end the show, why
not a chef turned rapper?
Why not, people?
Check out this personal chef in Texas,
Texas,
who is blowing up on
Tik Tok for his culinary
and lyrical skills. Check 'em out.
- ♪Yo, I use one whole egg
and a couple of guilts ♪
I've been asked measurements
by a couple of folks,
One half cup sugar, whole cup at the most,
And just whisk it and whisk
till you see the results
Ya,uh
Hit some cream in a sauce pan,
With vanilla you could
see I'm using off-brand
Now, it's time to mix
And I know it's tempting, but
only add a little at a time
It's called tempering.
(laughter)
- It's amazing.
Off brand, that's my favorite part.
Let's get this and see it
and say hi to josh watching
up fox 26 Houston at 3.
What's up josh?
(crowd cheering)
Oh my god, the off brand
vanilla was my favorite part,
So how did you come up with this.
- Man, I've always had
huge passion for cooking
also music, of course.
And I just combined both talents,
made some content,
put it on the internet and people love it.
- It's amazing. It makes me
want to cook and also rap,
which both will be horrible, but for me,
So you don't,
you don't have a rap name,
but people online have suggested several.
So we have to go through
these 'cause they're awesome.
2pots shakur.
(laughter)
That's amazing.
And chance the rapper with a W
you'd be the cooler one,
Lil baby back ribs.
Come on. That's awesome.
And my personal favorite is Meek meals.
(laughter)
- That's a good too.
- That's a good one.
So what's been the coolest part of this.
- Has to be when Gordon Ramsey,
he actually do it at my Tik
Tok video and he usually rips
people and their recipes,
but he had nothing but good
things to say about mine.
So that was awesome. That was great.
- You got to feel good.
It's like, like impressing Simon Cowell.
It's like job Well done.
- Yes, exactly.
- Well, thank you, exactly.
Thank you so much, Josh.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- (josh) Yeah, thank you.
(cheering and clapping)
Alright, that's not all though,
our season long partner pilot pin,
the go-to pin in the Kelly
Clarkson show likes to celebrate
those who create
fearlessly, just like you,
so they're going to be using
their friction erasable pen to
write you a check for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound
- Wow
( clapping and cheering)
- That's a lot of Meals, Meak meals.